And you put the point to say that is this last one, all the way at the end.
This corresponds to the mass having fully compressed the spring and again
it's stopping with 0 velocity for just that instant.
These other three points don't really make sense because they correspond to
since they're on this horizontal line here--this is the line of 0 velocity.
Anytime the mass is in between these extreme points of Xmax and -Xmax,
well it's going to be moving--so this doesn't make sense.
I will also tell you that when the object is swinging through so let's say
it's coming from this end and swinging through equilibrium.
When it goes through the equilibrium point, its velocity is maximized.
It's going very fast, as fast as it'll ever will go but will in this case it's going to the left.
Leftwards means negative, so that will correspond to this point.
We've already talked about what happens--it's going to compress the spring,
stop for a second, and then swing back through.
When it get through equilibrium on the swing through, well then it's going to the right
with maximum speed again corresponds to this point.